انْتَبِهُوا لِي يَا أَحْبَابْ عِنْدِي قِصَّةْ يَا أَصْحَابْ
عَنْ مَاجِدْ طِفْلٌ مَوْهُوبْ  لَكِنْ لَلأَسَفِ كَذَّابْ
كَذَّابْ  للأَسَفِ كَذَّابْ
هَذا اليَوْمَ مَاذَا صَارْ  سَكَبَ الْلَبَنَ عَلى الإِفْطَارْ
سَأَلَتْهُ مَامَا مَنْ سَكَبَهْ  قَالَ هُوَ العُصْفُورُ وَطَارْ
كَذَّابْ  للأَسَفِ كَذَّابْ
طَالَتْ أَنْفُهُ طَالَتْ طَالَتْ  جِدًّا جِدًّا حَتَّى مَالَتْ
هَذَا عَيْبٌ إَنَّكَ تَكْذِبْ  وَلْتَتَأَسَّفْ مَامَا قَالَتْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا
رَكَضَ مَاجِدُ يَلْعَبُ يَجْرِى فَاصْطَدَمَ بِإنَاءِ الزَّهْرِ
سَأَلَتْ مَامَا أَنْتَ كَسَرْتَهْ  كَذَبَ وَأَلْصَقَهَا بِالهِرِّ
كَذَّابْ  للأَسَفِ كَذَّابْ
لَكِنْ فَجْأَةْ طَالَتْ أَنْفُهْ  مَامَا مَنْ ذَلِكَ تَكْتَشِفُهْ
أُحْرِجَ مَاجِدُ مِمَّا فَعَلَ  واعْتَذَرَ وَآَلَمَهُ أَسَفُهْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا
مَاجِدْ دَخَلَ وَأَكَلَ الْحَلْوَى  وَاسْتَطْعَمَ في فَمِهِ الحَشْوَ
سَأَلَتْ ماما ماجِدَ عَنْهَا  أَنْكَرَ لَمْ يَسْأَلْهَا العَفْوَ
كَذَّابْ  للأَسَفِ كَذَّابْ
هَذِى المَرَّةْ طَالَتْ أَنْفُهْ جدًا جداً حَتَّى السَّقْفْ
فَبَكَى مَاجِدُ إِنِّي مُخْطِئ  وعُيُونٍ يَمْلَؤُهَا الخَوْفْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا
لَنْ أَكْذِبَ أَبَداً لَنْ أَفْعَلْ  الكَذبُ قَبِيحٌ بَلْ مُخْجِلْ
عَادَتْ أَنْفُهُ تَصْغُرُ تَصْغُرْ  وَكَمَا كَانَتْ مِثْلَ الأَوَّلْ
لن أَكْذِبْ أبدا لن أَكْذِبْ
قَالَتْ مَامَا اسْمَعْ مَاجِدْ  لَا تَكْذِبْ أَبَداً وَتُعَانِدْ
الصِّدْقُ سَيُنَجِيَكَ يا ولدي أَنْفُكَ دَوْماً يبقى شَاهِدْ
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لالا